At the end of this unit,
you'll do a project on building
a model that fits some data.
We'll give you some real world data and
you'll construct a model
that describes it.
And then you'll make a case for your
model as a good summary, a useful tool,
for understanding that data.
You'll then use that model to make
predictions about the future.
You'll use it to see, what is this
data going to look like in the future?
What are the incoming observations we
would expect to see based on what we've
seen in the past?
And by doing so you'll have a project in
your portfolio that demonstrates that
you know now how to build
a model of some data and
then validate it according
to some metrics.